we're going to turn now to a new cyber
threat a newly revealed technical flaw
that could affect everyday gadgets that
most of us have in our homes right now
tech firms are scrambling to get ahead
of criminals and the possibility that
they could gain full access to computer
systems all around the world
our chief national affairs and justice
correspondent jeff begaze is in
washington to show us what exactly is at
risk jeff good morning yeah tony there
is a lot at risk and that's why the
department of homeland security is
scrambling right now to get the word out
about this vulnerability which was
actually discovered by staffers of the
popular game minecraft cyber security
experts found that what's been called
log 4j affects a software tool used in a
range of devices including smart watches
tvs gaming consoles printers
even smart thermostats and cloud
services like apple's icloud are also at
risk the flaw could allow hackers to
access devices and the data stored on
them and then hold that information for
ransom tech giants like microsoft and
cisco have all sent out advisories the
government cyber security agency is
following up on all of that urging
people out there to update their
software as soon as possible nate
valuable information jeff thank you